lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar acerca del impuesto sucesorio
impuesto sucesorio y como el nombre del
impuesto implica es el impuesto sobre la
herencia o el legado de alguien cuando
alguien fallece es el impuesto sobre lo
que heredan sobre lo que dejan atrás ya
sea en su testamento o en su familia en
donde ellos indiquen
algunas veces se conoce como impuesto en
la herencia o impuesto a la herencia y
en algunos lugares se refiere a ello
como impuesto de la muerte la idea
general es que digamos que ahora todos
mis bienes valen 3 millones de dólares
yo valgo 3 millones de dólares y
entonces fallezca por lo que estos 3
millones de dólares van a mi herencia lo
que heredó pueden ser mis ahorros las
propiedades que tengo mi coche en fin
todo lo que yo poseo todo eso combinado
dan 3 millones de dólares que es lo que
yo voy a heredar y digamos que yo voy a
dejar todo lo que está en mi herencia
para mi hija
así que todo esto se lo voy a heredar a
mi hija en este momento es donde entra
el impuesto sucesorio o el impuesto a la
herencia cuánto dinero recibirá mi hija
resulta que para tres millones de
dólares en los eeuu
mi hija está exenta del impuesto pues en
las herencias de individuos los primeros
cinco millones de dólares están exentos
así que en este ejemplo donde yo he dado
tres millones de dólares
mi hija de hecho va a recibir los tres
millones íntegros ahora imaginemos que
yo tengo mucho más dinero digamos que
tengo seis millones de dólares en este
ejemplo tengo seis millones de dólares
todo esto va a mi herencia a mi herencia
después de mi muerte y ahora los
primeros cinco millones de dólares están
exentos del impuesto vamos a escribirlo
aquí está mi hija mi hija recibirá los
primeros cinco millones de dólares
íntegros
5 millones
pero el incremento por encima de esos 5
millones es decir el millón de dólares
que restan tendrá o se le aplicará el
impuesto sucesorio la tasa de ese
impuesto varía constantemente pero para
mantenerlo simple vamos a inventar que
el impuesto es el 35 por ciento así que
el millón de dólares que resta tendrá un
impuesto del 35 por ciento impuesto del
35 por ciento así que el gobierno
federal de los eeuu le impondrá el
impuesto de 35 por ciento a este millón
de dólares van a quitar 350 mil para
ellos mismos y el resto se lo darán a mi
hija ella recibirá 5 millones 650 mil
dólares ya que de este millón al que le
quitaron 350 mil pues le quedarán 650
mil en esta situación
mi hija recibiría recibiría 5.65
millones de dólares 5 puntos 65 millones
5 puntos 65 millones de dólares si yo
fuera súper rico
digamos que yo tengo vamos a elegir un
número con el que sea más fácil hacer
los cálculos
digamos que yo tengo yo tengo mil cinco
millones de dólares
en esta situación imaginaria por
supuesto los primeros 5 millones están
exentos del impuesto
por lo que mi hija
en esta situación
del millón de dólares que me queda le
aplicó el 35 por ciento
mil millones al 35%
aquí el gobierno federal se va a quedar
con 350 millones de dólares lo que le
dejará 650 millones de dólares a mi hija
en total tendrá estos 650 millones de
dólares para los 5 millones de dólares
que fueron exentos del impuesto tendrá
un gran total de 655 millones de dólares
y realmente no me preocuparía por el
futuro de ella con esta cantidad que
heredaría y todo esto es para que
ustedes comprendan cómo funciona el
impuesto sucesorio estos ejemplos que
vienen en el que están exentos 5
millones se trata para el impuesto de
herencia individual cuando una persona
fallece pero si esto se hace como una
pareja la cantidad que se exenta es de
10 millones por ejemplo si entre mi
esposo y yo tuviéramos estos mil 5
millones de dólares y digamos que bueno
yo fallezca y tenemos compartidos los
bienes él va a recibir toda esta
cantidad completa y cuando a él le
corresponda fallecer serán 10 millones
los que estén exentos en este caso si
fuera de edad o en pareja mi hija
recibiría completo los 6 millones de
dólares